Перший, другий, третій,
перший, другий, третій,
перший, другий, третій, перший.
Пласт — українська національна скаутська організація.
Займання скаутом є в центрі нашої мети.
Це значить пов'язати життя дітей,
переважно з міського довкілля, з природою.
Я народилася в Мюнхені, де мої батьки жили,
за професію я правник.
20 років займаюся пластом,
тут, у Великій Британії.
Я народилась у Львові,
мої батьки народились у Львові.
У Пласт я прийшла 1996 року та й там і залишилася.
Я працюю менеджеркою конгресів,
комітетів та нових центрів для PEN International.
Я закінчила філософський факультет
Львівського національного університету,
пізніше там захистила свою кандидатську роботу,
і друга моя освіта юридична.
Я працюю у Великобританії,
в Національній Службі Охорони Здоров'я,
уже понад 10 років,
і в Пласті я є насамперед виховниця,
але також станична, в станиці Лондон.
Станична — це керівник якоїсь місцевості,
і я відповідаю за Пласт
у столиці Великобританії — Лондон.
Обов’язки обираю собі сама.
Нема такого, що ти мусиш абощо.
Але одним словом, моя справа,
моя роль адміністративна.
Я виховниця гуртка «Акули» в юнацтві,
я референтка преси «Краю великого. Велика Британія»
Ну, і відповідно, коли ми робимо будь-які там заходи,
то я відповідаю за оцю менеджерську
складову або організаційну.
Моя роль полягає в тому, аби тримати наш гурт разом.
Також завдання станичної —
співпрацювати з іншими організаціями,
і я дуже багато працюю,
наприклад, з британськими скаутами,
з іншими українськими організаціями
тут, у Великобританії,
це СУМ — Спілка Української Молоді,
це СУБ — Спілка Українців
у Великій Британії, і так далі.
Тобто це є також більше представницька роль станичної.
Батько був фінансовим референтом
для ОУН, збирав великі гроші.
Тож, як наступали радянська армія,
він зрозумів, що йому не бути в Україні,
і також втікав на Захід
і теж опинився зрештою в Мюнхені.
Мама натомість була заарештована
гестапо в Берліні за зв'язки з ОУН,
тоді її вислали в концентраційний табір Равенсбрюк,
там висиділа два роки, майже два роки,
її передчасно звільнили,
і так вона лишилася в Німеччині.
Адаптуватися було дуже-дуже тяжко.
І фактично було також таке:
«Ну давай, ми вертаємося в Україну,
то ще потягнеться, але ми вернемося».
Тож у нас була на стриху готова валізка,
щоб на перших 2–3 дні,
щоб ми могли повертатися.
Перший рік, коли я переїхала,
це завжди є оцей момент
ностальгії за батьківщиною
і коли я прийшла на сходини,
де готувався вертеп
і пізніше ми всі поїхали разом готувати 12 страв,
ліпити вареники і все решта.
Це було таке відчуття дому
дуже потужне, дуже екзистинційне.
Пласт створився 1911 року, у Львові,
і засновниками Пласту були Олександр Тисовський,
Дрот було його прізвисько,
Іван Чмола та Петро Франко.
Петро Франко якраз син нашого
відомого письменника Івана Франка.
Дрот прочитав про скаутський рух у Великій Британії,
і вони створили дуже подібну скаутську організацію,
в основу якої стає служіння Батьківщині, служіння Богу
і служіння своєму народу.
12 квітня 1912 року відбувається
перша присяга пластунів у Львові,
і властиво, 12 квітня для нас,
пластунів, є дуже важлива дата,
бо це дата дня народження Пласту.
Була мала, дрібна еміграція
здається вже по Першій світовій війні.
Але головне і найважливіше —
перелам Другої світової війни,
де було майже виключно чоловіки молодого віку,
які одружуються, які родять дітей.
І все ж таки була потреба
тим дітям дати українське довкілля.
І це був головний мотиватор.
І 1947 року почали гуртувати такі перші гуртки,
1948 року відбувся перший з'їзд пластунів,
і заснувалися осередки в Манчестері,
в Лондоні, в Табі, в Нотінгем,
і десь в 1960-х роках робота розпалася.
Ми почали відновлювати Пласт тут від 2005–2006 року.
Почалося це все з трьох родин,
які приїхали в Англію з різних країн.
Ми зараз маємо команду
знову ж таки складену з тих людей,
які готові віддавати свій час
Пласту абсолютно безкоштовно
і без будь-яких очікувань.
Стосовно того, що ми зараз маємо зробити.
Чи всі пам'ятають правила безпеки на воді?
Я дуже прошу, щоб ви дивилися одне за одним,
особливо ті, хто зараз дістав вмілість.
Я хочу, щоб ви відчували цю відповідальність,
тому що це є частина складової
вашої пластової діяльності.
Ви маєте певні навички,
тому що ви спроможні допомогти також іншим.
За замовчуванням усі, хто йде туди зараз,
маєте вміти плавати,
але питання у тому, на якому рівні.
Для діаспори Пласт відіграє велику роль,
особливо стосовно тих дітей,
які народилися тут.
Це є спільнота, україномовна твоїх друзів,
з якими в тебе разом є якісь розваги,
з якими тобі добре.
Так ми підтримуємо ось цей контакт українськості
і формування спільноти,
тому що більшість наших дітей
автоматично стає друзями.
Правда, тому що вони проводять разом гарно час.
В моїх обставинах, коли моя родина проживає
і народилася фактично поза межами України,
цей зв'язок з Україною є дуже важливий.
Другий момент — це спілкування з природою.
Наше навчання відбувається
на тому, щоб розуміти зорі,
розуміти тварин, розуміти
рослини, розуміти землю.
І третя річ — це створення
певної української молоді,
яка готова не погоджуватися,
яка готова вчитися,
дуже глибко вчитися і повертати
це все надбання назад у свою культуру
і в свою націю.
Щоб показувати, чого українці можуть досягати,
яка наша історія, хто є видатними українцями.
У кожній своїй розмові з англійцями я кажу:
«А ви знаєте, цю коляду написав той?
А ви знаєте, українець зробив це?
А ви знаєте наших спортсменів?»
Тобто, я так би мовити, крокуючи
через своє британське життя,
так потрошки британців вчу української історії,
чим займаються українці, чого вони
досягають у своєму житті і так далі.
Ми з вами зайдемо у водний парк.
Ми маємо дві активності: перше — це буде ніндзя,
там буде дві команди, якось постараємося вас розділити,
щоб сили були рівні,
після того ми будемо мати
маленьку паузу і перейдем на понтони.
Теж будете падати у воду.
Словом, мені дуже сподобалося,
хтось з батьків спитав,
а шо буде, якщо діти упадуть у воду.
А я кажу, що по факту ми їдем туди,
щоб діти весь час падали у воду.
Тож буде успіх.
Я завжди мала, очевидно,
Пласт і всякі українські школи,
українська церква і це все грало.
Але так щоб я підписалася так,
як я є — я буду українкою помимо
всього інакшого, то тут через дитину.
Просто з дитиною мені українська
найближча, бо я то пригадувала,
я не знала німецьких пісень,
наприклад, колискових чи якихось інших.
То все було для мене іншої частини, то не була моя.
Майдан був для мене також
абсолютно вирішальним фактром,
ще одним таким вирішальним фактором
фокусуватися на Україну.
То було дійсно… То було неймовірно.
Я думаю, що перцепція
[чуттєве сприйняття зовнішніх предметів] того,
відчуття того, що є Україна,
напевно, за останні десятиліття
дуже сильно змінилося.
Я пам'ятаю, коли була геть маленька,
мені там було якихось нехай 10 років.
І я пам'ятаю, як мій батько тішився
і всі люди навколо тішились,
що ми прийняли цей акт Незалежності.
І я ще не розуміла, що це і про що це.
Але бачила, як це відчувається і переживається.
Думаю, що я змогла для себе пережити
щось таке глибоке,
коли відбувався Майдан.
Це було відчуття дуже глибокої
внутрішньої сили, яку зробили всі.
Це, напевно, і була для мене Україна.
В Пласт приходять діти в три роки,
і від трьох до шести років —
це пластуни-пташенята, ми так називаємо.
В шість років вони переходять на наступний рівень
— це пластуни-новаки.
Після того як вони закінчили,
от повних одинадцять років,
вони переходять в наступний улад —
це є улад юнацтва,
і вирішують, чи будуть вони
продовжувати займатися Пластом
вже як виховники.
Між вісімнадцять і тридцять п'ять років —
це улад старших пластунів,
як ми їх називаємо, і це властива,
така рушійна сила Пласту.
Після тридцяти п'яти у нас є улад сеньйорства,
я якраз належу до сеньйорів уже,
і майже всі наші виховники
в станиці Лондон уже є сеньйорами.
Тож почати пластувати можна майже від народження,
від трьох років, і залишитися в Пласті до глибокої старості.
Це в нас було закриття пластового року
для групи «Юнацтво».
І ми завжди намагаємось на відкриття
і закриття року зробити
щось для них таке атракційне,
щоб їм подобалося.
Ми завжди маємо тримати цей баланс,
між донесенням якихось серйозних речей,
але через гру, через те,
що їм буде приємно і що їх буде залучати.
З одного боку ми вирощуємо дійсно просто здорових дітей.
Здорових дітей з повноцінним кругозором
і, не знаю, самозарадністю.
З іншого боку ось момент національної ідентичності.
Пластовий закон складається з чотирнадцяти точок,
і вони говорять:
«Пластун є чесний, сумлінний,
доброзичливий, ввічливий,
завжди доброї гадки...»
Навіть якщо хтось робить те,
що я думаю неправильно,
з їхньої сторони воно все одно є якнайкраще,
такий сильний стержень, залишатися доброї гадки,
я думаю, для мене особисто
є дуже-дуже важливим.
Але це те, що прийшло з Пласту.
Скаутинг поширився, і скаути є всюди,
але ми є як пластуни, ми є всюди українськомовні.
І це, очевидно, великий виклик.
З іншого боку, це нас об’єднує,
бо ми є одинока скаутська організація,
яка працює глобально.
Пластунами стають раз і назавжди.
Коли ти склав свою пластову присягу,
ти в Пласті назавжди:
чи ти сьогодні безпосередньо працюєш у Пласті, чи ні,
це вже зовсім інше питання.
Дуже часто пластуни виходять з організації офіційно,
5–6 років мають перерву і тоді
назад вертаються в організацію.
Тобто пластуном не можна перестати бути.
Ним стають і ним залишаються.
Дитина, яка в п'ятому чи вшостому
поколінні вже проживає діаспорі,
вона чітко каже: «Я — українка».
Можна запитати: «А що такого корисного в тому?
Що такого цінного в тому?»
Твоє особисте щастя насправді залежить
від того наскільки ти себе знаєш.
Наскільки ти чесний із собою.
Наскільки ти можеш визначити,
що дає тобі це життя і що ти даєш життю.
Я думаю, що ось цей момент ідентичності,
цей момент вдячності, момент
корисності іншому — це є ці всі речі,
які ми Пластом охоплюємо.